Okay.
This week for our classic interview, we're
going to go back to when I spoke to Alec,
Kara Kotsanis about the bail bonds industry,
which is a horrible, horrible industry, which
I've covered before.
And this is sort of in the context of the
story.
We've covered a couple of times now with Shane
Cavenaugh from Portland, Oregon about Saudi
nationals, typically students who are charged
with crimes in the United States and ended
up being whisked back to Saudi Arabia evading
justice and the contrast between those wealthy
Saudis and what is effectively a kid gloves
treatment, uh, by virtue of the Saudi authorities
involvement compared to how the average person
in particularly a poor and lower middle class
people, how they are treated, including by
the bail bonds industry.
So back to my interview from February of 2016
with Alec Kerrick Kotsanis.
Take a look at this.
I'm joined today by Alec [inaudible], who's
a civil rights lawyer dedicated to transforming
the American criminal justice injustice system.
Alec, we've been talking about bail and the
bail bond system in the United States for
a very long time.
Let's sort of start at the most fundamental
level.
When someone is brought in to court, what
is the basis on which the amount of bail is
decided and whether there is even bail at
all.
So after someone's arrested in all 50 states,
they're, they're brought to jail and in most
circumstances they're told you're eligible
for release immediately, but you have to give
us some money first.
And in some places that decision is based
on a, a chart that is based purely on the
offense that the person has been charged with
and other places they go before.
Some officers, um, magistrate, some judge
and the judge just sort of picks a number,
an amount of money.
And typically that's happening without any
inquiry at all into whether the person can
afford that amount of money.
That's interestingly not the case in the district
of Columbia where I live in practice or in
any of the federal courts in any of the 50
states around the country.
In those systems, people are released prior
to trial without having to pay any money unless
the government sit there, a danger to the
community who are risk of flight.
And so in the federal system and in DC, decisions
about whether a human being is kept in a cage
prior to trial are made based on evidence
and about whether they're at danger rather
than based on someone's poverty.
But in all of the other states, um, whether
you stay in jail after you're arrested by
the police, it depends solely on whether you
can afford to pay bail.
And now explain how the bail bond system works.
As you mentioned, your ability to pay that
bail, uh, may vary drastically and it often
does.
So talk about what service a bail bondsman
provides to someone who has been set a bail
realistically that they cannot afford.
So in 46, we have what's called the commercial
bail bond industry.
There are four states that have outlawed bail
bondsman.
The United States and the Philippines are
the only two countries in the world, but still
allow commercial bail bondsman.
What this industry does is it preys upon the
people that are too poor to afford to pay
the bail that's been set by the court.
They come in and they say, if you give us
a percentage of that amount, um, we will tell
the court that will cover the rest.
Now they typically, because they control so
many state legislatures and, and local government
systems, they've typically passed rules that
actually protect them even from having to
pay, um, at all.
Even if you don't show ups, they're risky,
virtually nothing.
Um, what they then do is they tracked these
people in these incredibly onerous, exploitative
contracts.
So sometimes they might say, you give us 5%
of the money bail and then you agree to pay
us the rest at the highest allowable interest
rate under law for years.
So you could be like some of our clients,
you could be arrested by the police and then
you can be held in jail on a, on a bond you
can't afford.
And then you go to a bail bondsman, you make
a payment, and now you owe them money for
years.
And the very next day the prosecutor looks
at your case and says, there is no crime here
or there's not enough evidence, and they dismissed
the case.
Now you're stuck owing money to the bail bondsman
for a case that was never prosecuted and this
is the way in which the bail bond industry
transfers billions of dollars every year from
the poorest people in our society.
Those people that are accused of crimes and
their families who can't afford bail to some
of the richest people in the country, the
bail bond industry and the insurance companies
that underwrite them.
One of the, uh, incredible circumstances of
this industry is that on the one hand, the
bail bonds industry sometimes likes to defend
itself by saying, listen, if you're sitting
there in pretrial detention, it's going to
be tougher for you to build the strongest
case possible to defend yourself when your
court date ultimately comes.
At the same time though, Alec, that same industry
is lobbying all the time to put more alleged
crimes under the list, qualifying for pretrial
detention.
Unless you are able to pay bail, they're sort
of creating a bigger and bigger market for
themselves, aren't they?
They are.
There are about 500,000 human beings on any
given night in this country who are in a jail
cell because they cannot afford to pay bail.
That's the way they'd be able.
Industry likes it.
They want as many people as possible as potential
customers.
So they're constantly lobbying state and local
governments for more.
Another incredible thing that they do is they
lobby state and local governments for other
policies that subtly help them.
So for example, in the state of Louisiana,
if I'm arrested and brought to court for a
bail hearing, the public defender that represents
me, the prosecutor that's arguing against
me, the sheriff that brought me there, and
the judge that is making a decision about
my mail all take by statute, a percentage
cut of the money bail, but set in my case.
And that statute was put into place by the
bail bond industry to give everyone in the
system an incentive to keep bail.
Bond industry is thriving.
And that's the kind of perverse incentives
that we're seeing all over the country, um,
with the bail bond industry now.
And it was really interesting.
Oh, sorry, go ahead.
No, no, go.
I was going to say what's really interesting
about the point you just made is that'd be
up on industry likes to advertise itself as
helping to release people.
And yet in our lawsuits after we have received
them filed, we see a lot of fearmongering
by the Dale Bond Industry about, about how
well if, if you, if you get rid of the bail
bond industry, you're going to remember that
you're leasing all these criminals, which
is they're very, um, advertising slogan that
they been going by for years.
What's fascinating about it and the reason
why a lot of police and prosecutors and sheriffs
are really opposed to the bail industry is
that if you believe that a person is a danger
to the community and you think that person
could harm other people while they're awaiting
trial, why in the world would you release
that person just because they have money?
If someone is a dangerous Predator, I would
argue they're even more dangerous if they
have resources and money.
So the bail bond industry is advocating for
a system that releases Robert Durst, but that
cages Sandra bland.
And that is absolutely absurd.
Do you have data nationally on what percentage
of alleged perpetrators are not even offered
bail?
In other words, they're considered such a
risk to society that bail is not even an option.
And then how many are offered bail but ultimately
never pay it either directly or via bail bondsman.
And how many do pay the bail and get out?
Do we have some sort of sense of those numbers?
No.
And in fact, no one's keeping those numbers
precisely because of incentives involved here.
And the bail bond industry doesn't want there
to be decisions made about people's dangerousness.
They want people to be offered high money
bonds on the, on the chance they could get
the money together to pay it.
So when, when courts all around the country
in most states aren't ever making that determination
that someone is dangerous, they're just estimating.
If a judge thinks that a person is dangerous
in a state that uses a lot of commercial money
bail, they'll just estimate in the amount
of money that they think the person can't
afford.
So they'll say, you know, $1 million on the
hope that the person can't pay it.
You know, that very unconstitutional obviously.
But that's what's happening in courts all
over the country.
And so no one is keeping any kind of data
right now on the question that you asked,
which is sort of what's happening to people
that are, that are really dangerous and are
they being released on bail because they're
rich and, and things like that.
So we don't really know.
All we know is that the money bail system
is keeping hundreds of thousands of very low
risk, nonviolent and, and otherwise.
And offenders that we know through the data
aren't likely to commit new offenses.
Um, while they're pending trial, I'm in jail
just because they're poor.
I want to go back to something you sort of
alluded to, which is the sort of general lack
of risks that bail bondsman have fruit for
losing money.
They claim right that they deserve to earn
this sort of commission, typically 10% for
helping people get out of pretrial detention
because they are taking on risk, right?
If the alleged perpetrator
disappears after they've been bailed out by
the bail bondsmen bail bondsman is on the
hook for their entire Bale.
The reality though is that these bail bondsmen
individually have insurance and that if you
look at the numbers, it is very rare that
they actually are out anything close to 100%
of the bail for any individual alleged perpetrator.
They have a very solid insurance system in
place.
It's very true.
All of those empirical claims or the bond
industry are complete fabrications.
The other really interesting point is, um,
what they've negotiated for, and a lot of
states and a lot of jurisdictions is a grace
period.
So they don't have to, even if the person
does skip out, they don't have to make that
payment for two, three, four years.
Right.
And so what you see then is they rely on the
police.
Um, it's very, very common in our society
that the police will then pick somebody up
on a warrant because we've got the US marshals
and local police and sheriffs who are out
looking for people if they ever skip core.
And when those people are then brought back
in by the police, not by the bail industry,
the bail industry doesn't have to pay.
Um, so they, they sort of free ride on law
enforcement to, to assure themselves of never
having to put any risk up.
And as you say, even on the very, very, very
small number of cases where they are exposed
because they, the person skipped court, uh,
they have insurance to protect themselves
from that.
And it's actually those insurance companies,
not individual bail bonds people, but those
insurance companies that are providing a lot
of the lobbying and the money and the financial
support for a lot of these, these terrible
policies.
Okay.
And I think there's another example.
It's yet another example where they're sort
of capitalism for the profits while you socialize
the risk.
That's exactly right.
And, and what's really encouraging now as
you're seeing law enforcement leaders all
over the country, the Department of Justice,
federal prosecutors, local sheriffs, national
associations of police officers who are speaking
out against this because the system makes
absolutely no sense.
Um, it does not make sense to release people
who might be dangerous just because they're
rich.
It does not make sense to hold people in a
cage who might not, Ugh, oh, that's because
they're poor.
We've been speaking with Alec [inaudible]
civil rights lawyer.
Thanks so much for talking to us about this
really important issue.
Thanks for having me.